hi friends this is probably the most
exciting day of my life next to the
birth of my child
and my wedding day former wwe star gabby
tuff
came out as transgender on thursday via
instagram
and got candid about her journey i am
amazed at the overwhelming show of
support the 42 year old shared
this pic on instagram posing in front of
a framed photo of herself when she was
still known by her ring name
tyler rex gabby penned a lengthy caption
which read in part quote
unashamed unabashedly me this is the
side of me that has hidden in the
shadows
afraid and fearful of what the world
would think afraid of what my family
friends and followers would say
or do i am no longer afraid and i am no
longer fearful
i can now say with confidence that i
love myself
for who i am gabby who retired from the
wwe in 2014
noted that the past eight months have
been the darkest of her entire life
the emotional turmoil of being
transgender and having to face the world
has almost ended me on multiple
occasions
however the day i stopped caring about
what other people thought
was the day i truly became limitless and
allowed my authentic self
to come into the light i haven't even
begun to read
the messages i've just seen some of the
banners coming in and
i am blown away the athlete has been
married to her wife priscilla
since 2002 and they share a
nine-year-old daughter mia
gaby thanked her friends and family for
accepting her for who she is
adding i don't expect everyone to agree
or understand
it's not my place to change any of your
core beliefs
just know the outer shell may change but
the soul remains the same
i just want to say thank you to everyone
that held support for me
before the world knew you know who you
are on wednesday prior to coming out as
transgender gabby shared a tribute to
priscilla
calling her her twin flame quote we
stand by each other's side
fully supporting without judgment
without opinion bonded by lifetimes of
pain
heartache joy happiness passion
irreplaceable experiences
births and deaths and we are both free
and more in love than
any lifetime before on thursday gabby
thanked her fans for their love
and support on her insta story thank you
for everyone with the flood of
positive messages coming in i love you
all so much
and on friday she shared a montage of
clips
including this moment with priscilla
dancing
in the bathroom